yeah welcome to another five minute game
and it's playing d for c4 and down let's
see play play the bogo Indian I didn't
play this too often here g3 em yeah he
force the the most ambitious way to
learn to play g3's of course also a
possibility so c-5m intends to transpose
the position into some sort of hedgehog
white down answered with d5 though this
is a pretty typical porn sec it's a only
quite remarkable that it it is played
here because white has got a really
silly night on d 2 so um it's very young
uncommon to see this type of sacrifice
when you have this kind of lights on
yeah 95 don't really know what to think
about this I mean I think I'm if I play
a very very direct move let's say here
what is why doing seat XD five and now
night back or whatever I mean this is
just the next report from lack or isn't
it it's really hard to believe that the
sacrifice should work with
yeah okay so um he just retreated if i
go to f6 now hear ya okay let's do this
he needs to play you for now I mean if I
it's not working in this position then I
played d5 next move might have yeah
thanks this is just an extra porn the
center for for nothing okay the some
controls before square right edge for am
NOT f5 I want to go to f8 secure the
bishop yeah maybe he is intending to to
go B form maybe it's not terribly
dangerous I can take on before and some
why does not really a threatening much i
would like to play c4 actually but c4 he
might take on c4 with the to the urban
with the night but wait see 495 got
bishop a4 with the temple and then i can
take on c4 so let's go here this is just
the text on the before porn and if he
just protect this yeah exactly then i
can just play b5 and at the end of the
before porn is so just weakness
yeah 94 I can I can just go back to the
seven it's a no big deal and I've got
night a for coming covering here b5
covering f5 the g7 bishops covering all
the important corn squares and my big
threat is night a form and this
completely destroys the Kings the
queenside a tree okay so he just gives
away all this there was probably not
much II he could do anyway so let's
protect against g5 it's not really a big
threat but keep it simple okay and next
time the big bonus is moving okay the
only idea i'm seeing as bishop d 595
queen age 54 something like this looks
but insane but maybe it is Sir it is
viable attacking f7 and h7 same time
okay so try to exchange even more pieces
he needs to take what the night now I
think that we need to retreat instantly
so now the roof can now help intending
Queenie five maybe some not working on
instantly but close Scott down f-4s a
possibility I come on let's let's do
this i'm low on time anyway and it
really looks like it should win some way
didn't really calculate
I really hope this wins but the pep I
admit that I didn't really take this
game too serious anymore after what was
happening earlier but ok so is this at
least winning let's hope that's hope it
is those pawns are should be something
Jesus this is just a draw right no man
really bad I completely bungled this up
I didn't really pay any of any attention
anymore I thought everything winds and
this is rarely a good idea to to think
that
now you can win this on time if you want
yeah this is the repetition now men have
such a fool I mean I thought I really
ate it would win automatically and then
yeah let's say let's say here Quincy
eight or something I don't know rook
takes you towards winning ok- 7-8 this
also is winning how how did I really
this is even rises even winning also
this is winning see 355 of course Bishop
5 lower 5500 Bishop t5 it's so easy
should be fine oh man I'm such a fool I
just have a look it cannot take on
before of course c2 and it promotes and
what to see what does he playing if you
play something like this it's just be
three aha and of course two pawns are
decisive it takes the bishop is just
ideally placed on d5 yes has no way to
defend against the pawns yeah you
witnessed some fool not winning with
plus 9 or whatever it was ok thanks for
watching this game anyway
you